Baker I have done it yes I have designed
the cover of the next buyer magazine all
by myself no no no need to thank me well
I'm not going to thank you because you
can't just design the cover by yourself
all the designers involved all the top
editors sign off on it somebody's no no
look at this yeah sackboy what's not to
like ok I'll see what I can do
i'm here with alex evans the co-founder
of Media Molecule and the maker of my
absolute most anticipated PlayStation 3
title of ever little big planet Alex
thank you for being here give us the
rundown what is a little big planet
that's a killer question I think little
big planet is a game where you can
create your own games so we call it
creative gaming but you come to it you'd
play levels and then as a result playing
those levels you're inspired hopefully
to make a new case character and your
costume or even an entire level and it's
all multiplayer right so you can have
four players at once online all making a
level off together absolutely absolutely
so we actually don't distinguish mean
online and local players so it's awesome
because you can just jack in another pad
on the PlayStation and you can have like
two versus two you can have like two got
two guys on this sofa and then like
individuals over here it's a global
launch so hopefully we'll get people
from all different characters and one of
the new things actually that we've put
in there is a lip-syncing so when you
make up your character and you're using
like the headset voice over IP things
and the character will actually
lip-synched what you say which are which
is one of my favorite little features in
there now I mean this really just it
sounds complicated when you hear a fact
like you know making my own video game
like that doesn't really sound like some
of it anybody can do yeah no I mean so
I'll take on it was how do we make it
fun so it does take time to make an
awesome massive level if you want to you
can just remix but if you want to use
remix existing one so we give you whole
chunks of gameplay so if you're the kind
of person who just wants to like like 20
minutes to kill you can do that too and
then really it's making it available to
the broadest possible audience so we try
and cater to people who just are
basically decorating or remix Inge and
then the other end of the extreme
obviously got these creative guys you
see what people do online and it's
always mind-blowing like how much detail
they can go in till you give them an
inch they take a while you know now how
do you deal with the the flood of
user-created game levels that are going
to you know appear on these servers
within you know days of the game
launching yeah well I mean we can't
change human nature it's going to happen
as you say so so we have kind of two
routes to that one is that I hope that
the good stuff will bubble to the top
and people will tend to prefer we have
flagging and tagging
there's web stuff Alex this is far and
away the best thing on playstation3 ever
when when do we get to play it October
so we're right finishing up right now
and then if you're lucky enough to get
on the beetle beta trial you may even
get it sooner than that so I'm looking
forward to seeing what people make come
October okay well i will give you my
card and you can put me in the beta
absolutely man this is going to fly off
the shelves you know that reminds me
when I was signing a Peter Molyneux is
showing fable 2 he said his next game is
going to be such a significant
scientific achievement that will be
putting it on the cover of wire yeah
true but we should get on top of that
really quick you know what let me just
let me mock that up fable 2 ah it's done
photoshop's for suckers man hi everybody
i'm here with Peter Molyneux who is the
creative director of fable two for the
xbox 360 um Peter looking at this game
that what the phrase that springs to my
mind is massively single player would
you agree I said that's a very
interesting way of putting I know what
you're where you're coming from them
well you're suggesting is that the coop
the way that we've done the call means
that you can share the experience while
still being in your single-player world
and I you know I really like that idea
for me sometimes I don't want the
massively multiplayer in your face
experience I just want to hang out with
my friends and it's super easy to do
that with so i'll be playing the single
player game and hacking up some monsters
and playing with my dog and my family
but along the way I will see things to
tell me that my friends are also playing
their single player games right well
what actually happens is that your
friends are constantly sending them
there where they are in their game to
your 360 and you'll see if you still
standing let's say you stand in bow
stowmarket you'll see this ghostly or
Wonder pass that's one of your friends
wondering going through bowerstone in
their single player game you can walk up
to that that or little orbs you
immediately you walk up to them the
microphone will activate you can also
use the keyboard you can choose to give
them gifts you can choose to look at
their stat so you can look at that
process or progress to the game or you
can suppress a button and invite
to your world and then the key thing is
which I also love when they leave your
world they take with them the experience
and the gold they earned while they're
in your world and take it back into
their world now you're also doing
something where you're going to release
an xbox live arcade game and then in
that game we'd be able to make money
that you can take into fable 2 when that
comes out that's right we've got the
system which is we've worked on this
little SDK meaning that we can interface
to third-party products and if those 30
party products like there's three of
these on the xbox live arcade games
which are being released six weeks
before favor to you can go in there play
those earn fable two gold and then when
you buy fable two you can import that
gold into your fable two game you can
continue to do that and I hope that
we're going to extend this out so that
there'll be some websites you can earn
fable two golems so you could fly fly if
able to go gold making game at work and
then when you go home in the evening you
can import that money be able to sounds
so interesting when are we going to be
able to play it at one minute past
twelve sometime in October Peter thank
you so much for being here thank you
you